because like i i feel like i would game
more like there's one console i've
really really [ __ ] won and it's the
steam deck
yeah yeah yeah yeah because like so many
times i'm just not fun to play on the
steam day actually yeah yeah because i
know it's it's it's less about just
the scene deck itself and it's more
there's so many games i just want to
play on the go yeah right because
because like
especially now we're traveling so much
and you know i don't stream as often as
you guys you know there's there's less
there's less time where i like sit down
in front of the pc or on account uh and
i game you know but if if there was like
that that's why like the console i game
the most on is probably like whenever i
play a switch game because it's just so
easy to just pick up whenever i need to
play it and just continue it uh at my
own convenience and like i was always
looking for a console to play the more
intensive games on uh while also going
on the go and like the steam deck seems
perfect for that but my god is it like
impossible to get right now yeah the
waiting list for that is
just like some people have got it i'm
like how the [ __ ] did you get it yeah
you sell your blood to
yeah i mean i i've seen like the prices
on ebay and like twice to triple the
price um and the waiting list i think
right now is like a few months so it's
not too bad only a few months that's
that's i i say that's not too bad
because i know like the people who got
like the first shipping of it they had
to like sign up a year plus before i
believe [ __ ] so i've heard mixed
things about it there's some good things
some bad things but overall i think uh i
think it's good yeah i've seen what's
the mixed things you've heard about it
uh i think i saw that the uh some games
it struggles with i can't remember what
i saw i remember there was some
downsides i can't remember though i
bought this
weeks ago i watched these videos right i
remember it wasn't perfect yeah yeah
yeah yeah i mean when is it when is it
yeah
yeah as like i'm not like i'm not like
uh you know i don't really care about
the frame rates or like the fps or
whatever too much you know i just want a
competent gaming experience on the go
for some games that i would normally
play on the pc or somewhere else and
that's seems that's all i really want
from the steam deck and that seems like
the perfect console to what i need right
now i'm sorry yeah yeah definitely damn
what are you playing now joey how's
kirby
i mean i haven't done the post game
stuff yet yeah but um yeah i don't know
i've just kind of been like [ __ ]
around just trying to play a bunch of
stuff i started playing uh kaizo emerald
which is like one of the honest pokemon
mods oh
that mod is hard as [ __ ]
it is so it took me six hours to beat
the first gym jesus christ yeah it's
hard as [ __ ] why is it hard because
not only is like well first of all every
trainer is unavoidable so you have to
fight every trainer and every trainer
is optimized so literally every trainer
fight is like fighting a professional
pokemon player wow so like the moves are
optimized
and like all the ivs are optimized and
everything
and you're basically just going against
that jesus christ and it's it's it's
intense as [ __ ] have you seen those
people beating the pokemon games with
level one pokemon oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
right yeah yeah well they're like
because you swap out poison substitute
they see all the moments
yeah ever like you're like i'll try and
play pokemon competitively you play and
then someone's like substitute then make
poison spikes yeah reflect and he's like
stop let me hit it let me hit your
pokemon
literally literally i knew it was bad
because for one like the first rival
fight yeah it just spammed sand attack
like seven times
and then it just slowly drained my
pokemon to the point where i lost the
first battle oh my god this isn't gonna
go well at all
oh [ __ ] i want to get more pokemon runs
yeah that's so fun that's like so i'm
probably going to continue that because
that's just like you know as like a long
time pokemon game i'm like this is the
first time where i'm like finally a
pokemon game is actually a challenge
finally a worthy opponent finally a
worthy opponent like you thought you
thought nuzlocks were hard like this
game is like [ __ ] hard yeah so what's
the base game that mods uh pokemon
emerald
it's all the mods are on like emerald
right it's usually like third gen yeah
like
i don't know maybe it's because it's
like
a fan favorite or like uh you know it's
i mean it's a solid game yeah yeah yeah
but there's also a lot of mods for you
know like you know gen 4 and stuff like
that there's tons of monsters like
breath of the wild and stuff i don't
know how yeah i mean it sounds cool
though i really want to play like
multiple like breath of the wild like
switch games but i'm also scared to [ __ ]
my switches yeah yeah exactly right well
breath of the wild is one of the games
where you can definitely see that being
like a mods have modest heaven you know
oh yeah because you have so much freedom
in that game as it is
in the base game you know i can't
imagine how it would be i've seen like
so many cool like mod videos
everything's among us
like everyone's at the among us
[Laughter]
i like it i just like it
it's like the one the [ __ ] uh the
point crow video where like you say
shrek it summons 10 shreks into the game
oh yeah yeah
which is the dumbest video but it was so
fun to watch yeah yeah like when is
among us gonna die when am i gonna stop
when am i gonna stop finding amongst
memes funny because i thought i would
like
i feel like they've gotten funnier i
don't i don't i don't know why
because they're starting to become
ironic that's why yeah i see the among
us vr yeah yeah yeah yeah i was going to
say it yeah it looks good it looks funny
that generally looks good that might be
like a game i can finally finally get vr
just going for the clips of like xbox
mics and someone's like this with their
ammonia
dude are you [ __ ] it was this guy
i can't wait i can't i can't wait to the
credit card on on vr you're like
i'm so hyped freddy i actually looked
awesome yeah yeah it looks fun yeah i
can't wait for the absolutely i'm hoping
that they do like
include the voice chat within the among
those games this time yeah proximity
that'd be awesome because i imagine like
having to like log into discord in vr
like having to like log out through
proximity chat yeah yeah yeah i also it
would be also perfect if like you did it
on the omnidirectional uh like moving
pad as well like oh yeah we have to like
run through the halls and [ __ ] that was
yeah yeah yeah when's that coming out
because i saw the trailer no idea they
didn't have a release date which
normally means
whenever the [ __ ] they finish it
it's probably a while which could be
next year
they should i hope they charge for it
because i wanted to i have worth their
time yeah yeah i mean it feels like this
has this because they completely just
remade the game right so they've
basically just built a new game
essentially from the ground up basically
i don't think they could have used
anything from their previous
previous game which was originally a
mobile game to go in full-on vr
so yeah i'm i'm very excited to try it
out might finally be able to like dust
off the via uh not the vive the valve
valve index which i've never still used
mine it's pretty good vr chat's pretty
fun yeah yeah
it's just such a such a hassle to set up
yeah i kind of wish i got the oculus or
whatever which because that just seems
so much more convenient than like you
know
i get you get more freedom with the
index and everything and it's like
higher resolution but i still haven't
streamed on the my oscilloscope just
because i'm like dreading to set it up
you optimize the index it's because i
have the things permanently up there
yeah super easy i literally just plug in
the headset open up steam and i'm i'm
literally doing it so it's it's super
painless for me even then i still get
tired doing it i get exhausted yeah
after like three four hours of like
running around in vr i'm like i'm like
spent i'm like i'm surprised you can't
even spend that long like i can't i
can't go more than like two hours yeah
in any game yeah yeah well it's really
good it's like chat it's so good like
the mods on it and the games in vr chat
are so good you eat your heart's like a
book
uh yeah but i mean uh i guess this is uh
this is gonna be i guess we have a bunch
of guests coming on there yeah yeah
that's right so this is gonna be the
last boys episode for uh for a while
because i'm sorry people are happy about
because we've had like the longest
period of no guess yeah and i feel like
you can tell because people are like
what are they when's the next guest too
it's it's our bad i mean it's been hard
because you know the guests have been
limited because
japan has uh can't be like let's invite
chris on a [ __ ] tenth time yeah
exactly we could have we wanted to we
could have invited back more yes we
thought we kind of just want to try and
keep keep trying
yeah so hopefully if you guys want more
guest episode you'll be getting a lot
coming yeah now that the world is
opening up it's kind of like the
floodgates are now
i'm sure i'm sure i i can't wait for the
what are the boys gonna just go back to
the three of them because we're probably
gonna have a lot of guest episodes
yeah so i know people are gonna say that
because people but people do like the
people don't like the non-guest episodes
people do actually really like them i
know a lot of people say that they're
their favorites yeah of course yeah uh
but yeah we have a lot of guests and
then we'll try and sprinkle in ours uh
between yeah it'd be interesting to see
how people like it yeah it's gonna be a
new kind of trash taste i think it's uh
season three
i guess it kind of is season three